I'm sorry I cleared the uh work the work
session for House Bill 368 open at this
time thank
you try
I'll just
stop thank you thank you madam
chair
WR jeez I've got two buttons instead of
one to deal with here so um
so this bill was um to allow uh families
to come to this state um for uh uh
health care for their transgender
child
and um to allow them to get care here
that they may not be able to get in
their own
State uh and
to allow the the care provider to hold
the the information of what care that
child receives uh and not uh send that
information across state
lines um the
U the challenge I believe is what is
legally possible to help a family avoid
prosecution in the state that they have
come
from and I'm
have believe we have some information in
front of us that would help us clarify
what can't be done based on the US
Constitution and if uh representative
Lon would like to make us aware of that
information uh thank you madam chair um
one of the big things that that we have
within the US Constitution is how the
different states work together um in
article 4 section two um it states in
the second Clause a person charged in
any state with treason felony or other
crime who shall flee from Justice and be
found in another state shall on demand
of the executive authority of the state
from which he fled be delivered up to be
removed to the state having jurisdiction
of the crime uh the most important part
is looking to some of the case history
around this because in order for this to
hold the crime needs to have occurred in
the state who is requesting the person
um having a crime exist when somebody
leaves that state and then try to reach
into that other state is one of those
areas where where those demands would
not be valid in the first place and we
we need to make sure that by saying that
we are not going to comply with other
states laws that also would impact if
there was something of referral or care
happening within another state um and
that would only be subject to those who
are actually in the property of that
state so this actually shows that the
providers in New Hampshire would not be
subject to those laws and would be
something that should be vigorously
defended by the Attorney General because
it would be improper for another state
to charge somebody in New Hampshire for
their actions in New Hampshire that
moves far beyond this relationship
between the
states so and and I I I also want to say
that I absolutely understand um the
intention behind this bill and the
necessity to make sure that people know
that they're welcome uh my I do have
another question around this bill
because I'm not it sounds I'm not sure
if um transgender care is suffering the
same shortages and backlogs that are
being experienced in other parts of
healthcare um are our kids here in New
Hampshire that have need for these
Services um already able to get all the
appointments that they need or is there
already more demand than they're able to
accommodate not sure if you know
that that's a good question um I know
that at one time that was an issue um
the biggest issue that I've seen so far
is what therapists will accept payment
from
Medicaid um they may be willing to offer
their services but not for
free and um they need to get paid for
what they would typically be paid for uh
for taking care of any client so that's
that's an issue that's outside the scope
of of this but there are there are
therapists there are therapists that can
provide um the services right now it's
just making sure people can find
them
so thank you I if if um this area of
medicine is actually fully staffed and
fully fully uh meeting all of the
demands I hope that they can pass on how
they're doing so well with the rest of
the of the healthcare profession um my
other one concern about this is I
recognize that there's other states who
have already had this um Sanctuary type
policy for these procedures but several
of those are ones who have large centers
of excellence for transgender care and
um to me if I were to go out of state to
seek care for my child I would most
likely go to one of these areas with a
center of excellence regardless of what
treatment it's for so um I'm concerned
both about the impact on kids in New
Hampshire who need access to this care
and also whether that would have um a
family come here to New Hampshire when
they may be able to um get their medical
needs treated U more comprehensively in
another state simply because they have a
larger and more robust system um when
you look to some of the websites that
talk about the provision of care in New
Hampshire there's a lot of referrals we
already do out of state to to um
Massachusetts because they do so
much understood um there are there are a
few that offer similar a similar thing
um uh this bill was is brought forward
as to give another option for people to
come to our state uh and maybe um uh
encourage them if they would like to
stay in this state that's another member
of the of the
community um and that was that was part
of the impetus for introducing this bill
is not to not to U um have them
questioned whether they would be
welcomed or not but provide be able to
provide service especially that we do
have the facility and at Dartmouth
Hitchcock uh that can provide services
which it's not just in U Lebanon it's
all they also offer some of their
services in
Manchester uh the are um yeah yeses
Missour yeah so we request requested
information and we haven't received what
we requested yet from Dartmouth
Hitchcock in regards to that so that's a
of of a little bit of concern to me too
is that they're not getting
us information that I believe is needed
for us to proceed did they I I don't
know that we asked for that information
for this bill we did ask it for 619 yeah
I mean to me they kind there's kind of
some overlap in in some of the
information so I think what's helpful
information that we would receive about
that would also pertain to some pieces
of this my
opinion yes thank you and if I if I can
add to that so what Dartmouth Hitchcock
is supposed to be you know the best and
they do the most um
complex um procedures that's offered for
this kind of care um talking about
surgery and they also um you know will
prescribe puberty block loers and
hormones and they also have um
therapists who are specially trained in
this area um they're supposed to be in
the state one of the best but so far we
all we've received from them is a
cross-sectional survey on um you know uh
suicidality
after um puberty blockers are initiated
and a study that has an N of
104 and very disjointed and not specific
they didn't send us anything robust and
if this is what the best care is basing
their um procedures and their policies
on um I'm a little concerned and I don't
think that it's appropriate to entice
people to come here to find to get that
service
provided um if this is the evidence that
they're providing legislators for what
they're
doing well I'd have to agree I can't
deny that uh on the other hand uh they
they they do exist and they do offer uh
high quality care to their patients um
whe they're providing us the information
we need it's a whole another story so um
but uh uh this uh this legislation was
to least remove a barrier that uh I was
made aware of by physicians in this
state uh because they were they were
challenged by uh the question of should
they release information outside the
state that might uh cause um a problem
or or a problem for the the family um as
far as the information that's shared and
would that be a legal problem uh that
would cause um someone to be prosecuted
uh so they are concerned about releasing
that form of insul that form of
information um without essentially
without the approval of the the family
because it's going to a legal entity
um I've I did a quick look at the
information you provided here and it
talks about the physical individual but
it doesn't talk about what information
can be shared across state lines and
that's that's part of what this this
bill is all about is the information
that could be shared if if a family and
a child comes to New Hampshire um so it
it comes down if if they're considering
getting care in another state is to have
uh New Hampshire be one of those options
and uh to make our uh medical people
aware that they don't necessarily have
to share information to another state
that could be used to
prosecute a family uh and um that might
be an issue that a family is concerned
about but it also would allow that if a
family wants that information to be
shared they would have that
option I have a question um I wrote it I
wrote this question down when we had our
very first hearing about this um that
what if one parent wants surgery for
their child and the other
doesn't how does that work and and that
would be beyond the scope of this bill
and that that's something that would
have they would have to work that out in
court as far as is the is the parent um
does one parent have control over the
health care of or if they're split up
right you know and then maybe maybe one
lives in a different state and things
like that so there's a lot of nuances
that's that's a yeah an issue associated
with the divorce of that family yeah go
ahead Le then I have a follow up
yes thank you madam chair um so I just
have another so to jump off what you
were saying about the information
gathering um I only see that um it
basically says that we can't our state
will not honor foreign subpoenas for
information um from other states right
that's correct um so I think that's
where it drifts into the territory of
this article 4 um of the US Constitution
um that you know we are not to interfere
with that kind of um extradition whether
it's a person or information I think
that it
may kind of enter the area of
interfering with due process of people
who are being prosecuted in those States
because now they're not going to be able
our state is actively restricting their
ability to extract evidence and I
understand that there's ideological
opposition OPP to um another State's
laws perhaps but
um that's why the different states have
um the ability to make the own their own
laws that govern their own States and
um it's it just doesn't seem like this
is within our authority to
do yeah that was a question of mine has
um representative Canon has any
conversations been with the attorney
general about this especially
constitutionally um from what what
representative Lon read
um it it seems clear to me about the
constitutionality of this but I don't
know if a con conversation has been had
with any higher ups in the AG's
office um we haven't contacted the
Attorney General specifically um
I'm looking
at yeah I guess for me it's the the
whole thing is the the overreach
and you know across
States we can't override an other states
I'm looking at the methodology note from
the
court
um the Attorney General was not
specifically contacted by uh
us
um I know that OS had this and believed
that it could be enacted here that all
points were valid so
um the
um so I think and and I was reading
through this this piece that
representative Lon provided and and I'm
looking at a bolded area says an accused
will however be discharged on habus
Corpus he shows by clear satisfactory
evidence that he was outside the
demanding State when the crime occurred
the following sentence if however
evidence is conflicting hius Corpus is
not the proper proceeding to try the
question of an alibi
so I think
um
where similar bills have passed other uh
legislative bodies in other states they
would have the same issue and currently
I don't know of any court case against
this implementation in other states um I
would I would like to proceed to offer
this as an option as as something that's
that's there for our medical personnel
as far as the question goes of can I
release should I release this
information knowing that by releasing it
I'm putting a family and a child at risk
in the state that they live in um it's
not necessarily requiring that the the
state is asking I need this family to
come back to Texas for instance to be
processed it's it it's the family went
to New Hampshire got some services
medical services went back to
Texas the question is then can Texas
prosecute that family for getting care
in another state uh and
and do we alleviate the question in the
minds of the medical people providing
that care because some sometimes it may
be should I even provide this care
because there is the potential that the
family could be end up in a legal
situation with the state that they came
from um so part of this is to put it in
our own statute that says no they can't
they can't be processed they can't be
prosecuted in another
state for just providing information or
that a family can't be prosecuted if
they've gotten s uh medical service here
uh and the information is provided by a
medical Prof should not be provided by a
medical professional here it's in in
some ways it it goes beyond the scope of
HIPPA uh it's it's says that if they
come to this state um the medical
professional can keep that information
here even if rest uh requested by a um a
court yes represent just clarification
on um you know receiving gender
affirming Health Care you know or mental
health care so gender affirming Health
Care is that inclusive then of
transition surgeries on
minors that that would be um as as a
part of the standards of care that a
child child at anyone is supposed to
have uh be involved working with a
therapist as well as with a psychologist
right but so and what if though the
decision was made from a family out of
state they wanted their child to undergo
um or the child wanted to go gender
reassignment surgery is that this bill
would in like that would make that that
that would be a possib it comes down to
whatever Services we offer here in New
Hampshire that are legal in New
Hampshire it does not it does not say
that we could offer anything more yeah
and I guess that's my struggle because I
haven't heard a definite answer from
Dartmouth Hitchcock as to what exactly
they are providing right now actually on
their website they State they they do
not provide gender um gender surgery to
those under the age of 18 they said that
on their website but when they were here
they they weren't able to uh she still
was not able to provide that Clarity and
even in the emails that we've sent we've
still got not gotten that definite
answer so I'm just that's our the part I
struggle with this this
bill essentially it if a family comes
here
for transgender care it's whatever the
legal definition is here it does not
change our
statutes as as far as the services that
can be offered it does not give them any
additional benefit it would be the same
medical services that we provide to
transgender children here in in in New
Hampshire I um sorry I go
ahead my question would be about how
frequently um these these children are
meeting with the different providers how
often they're having these therapy
sessions and and Psychotherapy sessions
and how often they're doing this in
order to have that uh more rigorous
support that is provided for in the
guidelin so that they are getting that
ongoing support through this whole
transition process do you know how
frequently they would be meeting with
providers
um in some cases it's it's every month
so then it would be up to the family if
they want to come here to New Hampshire
and make sure that they're here every
month and that would be their
decision okay thank you that's pretty
helpful it seems that it would be it
would be a really big challenge for a
family to maintain their residency in
another state when they're coming
monthly for care um and to me it almost
seems like a family in that situation i'
I've seen PL of families move for a
parents job or for another need moving
to another state for other types of
medical care and actually making a move
even if they do maintain their home and
rent it to somebody in the interim um if
somebody were to move from Texas to New
Hampshire in order to get this care uh
that would be a matter of a state then
interfering with somebody who is a
former resident of that state I know
that there's already been push back
against California trying to tax former
residents of New Hampshire former
residents of California
um after leaving the state and there's a
large push back on that idea of of a
state laying claim to somebody who once
lived in that state and so I guess I'm
I'm I appreciate the goal of trying to
make sure that this is more welcoming
for these kids and their families but
I'm I'm wondering if you know flying
back and forth monthly is even the best
provision of care especially because
very few of these states with these
rules even have direct flights to New
Hampshire and I appreciate app being
welcoming but I'm also looking at the
actual tactical e efforts of it I I
understand the concern um but does that
go beyond the scope of our bill this
this bill is just to put it in statute
that it's here especially to protect our
medical professionals if a family
decides that they want to
um live here temporarily and can afford
their own situation to come up here and
uh rent a piece of property and then
it's the it's their decision to do that
uh and their decision is it as to what
um charges they might be facing in their
own state so that's a family decision uh
is to but to provide essentially provide
um especially for our own medical
professionals that they don't have to
worry about the legal issues about
providing care it it then it comes down
to does a family want to fact in that
they would have to be here on a regular
basis to provide that care that's a
family decision not the state decision
the state here should be focused on and
the issue here is can we protect our
medical professionals that can they hold
on to the information if if if that
information is requested from out of
state if a family decides that that to
get the care that they need they need to
work out the arrangements for uh how
they will do that um that's their
responsibility it's not the
responsibility in this
bill um that's that's beyond the scope
uh thank you I appreciate that my
concern is just o over how practical of
an option this may be compared to the
cost um to the state to potentially
defend a a lawsuit against us if it is
found to be unconstitutional um I
recognize that um there may not be any
challenges to California's um statute on
this
but just because a suit hasn't been
brought about the constitutionality in
another state doesn't mean that uh
doesn't mean that it won't be coming in
the future and that could have a really
really hard large fiscal impact when
this is perhaps something that would be
better as a fine-tuned um approach to
the ultimate privacy of people's medical
records and to better protect the
Privacy the the sharing of anybody's
medical records and to just better
enforce New Hampshire privacy laws
around medical privacy that are in
excess of that of HIPPA which is allowed
and I think that that might be a more
elegant solution that addresses both the
needs of this community and more broadly
addresses the needs of granite Staters
and um while I appreciate I I appreciate
everything behind this bill I
just it just doesn't seem to be the most
effective use of resources in order to
put out that welcome that that's that's
my large my largest concern is that
there's so many challenges to it and I'm
not sure how effective it would be even
if we did go through all of those steps
put the state at risk in order to offer
this when we may not be the destination
of choice anyways representative Canon
is is there any openness to um possibly
creating an interim study surrounding
this to so we can get
more information from Dartmouth
Hitchcock
and
um cuz that's for me that's just this
this big question mark that with all the
hearings we've had
still has not made me feel comfortable
with what I've heard would you like to
move that
motion I
would I'd second
that okay then um because a motion's
been made there is a second we have to
act on this on this motion so um I would
like to know uh how many are in favor
and how many are
not move
forward so we have three in favor and
one no so um so I believe that that's
going to be what we will recomm
recommend um to the full committee when
we
meet thank you thank you I I think just
we did have a or tried to have a hearing
on this previously and I it seems like
we've had you know we've presented our
our questions and everything about it
and with what's still um I would
actually love to hear from the AG too I
I would I'd want to hear make sure we're
not crossing any constitutional
boundaries because I'm a big fan of that
Constitution I I will see what I can get
for an answer okay yeah no I this is I'd
like to dig into it more personally so
okay yeah so yeah there could be
overreach on this today and there could
be overreach on a different issue in the
future I think that it's important to
make sure we protect all of our citizens
and people who visit the state I just
want to make sure we do it in the right
way so thank you for bringing the bill
it sounds good okay thank you all so
declared this work session over so then
what happens
after yes so this the this will be the
subcommittee recommendation
that then gets voted voted on on the
13th thank you sorry you had to be by
yourself
e
um we are back together again and it's
uh good to see a few more faces around
this than we had this morning so that's
very very good to see um I'd like to
start discussing some of the issues
around the conversion therapy and the
discussions and some of the testimony
that we heard um last last we met for
the public hearing um there was
testimony from uh Mr urel from glad
where he stayed that gender identity was
fixed um but unfortunately that is not
consistent with the guidelines and
information and the world Professional
Association of transgender Health
standard of care 8 guidelines I have
provided a copy of seven pages from
those guidelines it's what begins with
the titling of chapter six
adolescence so I will read you just a
couple little dots um from here first
off on this adolescence um the this
chapter applies to adolescence from the
start of puberty into the age of legal
majority in most places that's 18 some
countries it's 15 and some places it's
as high as 21 years of age all of the W
paath guidelines are all sensitive to
whatever the legal realities are in the
area of treatment and they provide great
accommodation for that so speaking to
the issue around gender identity and
whether it is fixed from the start um
initi
when care was provided to adolescents
they were those adolescents who had been
clear and persistent from the time that
they were first born uh or close to when
they were first born and it was a very
highly screened um group that did not
include as many people as there are
today um so if we look on the second
page so it's s44 down to near the bottom
the bottom of the second to last
paragraph it states that um for some
youth gender ident identity development
appears fixed and is often expressed
from a young age while for others there
may be a developmental process that
contributes to gender identity over time
speaks to some studies and then flipping
to the next page starting halfway
through the fourth line it states it is
important to note it is not possible to
distinguish between those for whom
gender identity may seem fixed from
birth and those for whom gender identity
development appears to be a
developmental process since it is
impossible to definitively delineate the
contributions of various factors
contributing to the gender identity
development for any given young person a
comprehensive clinical approach is
important and necessary and then
continues conceptualization of gender
identity by shifting from dichotomus for
example binary categorization of male
and female to a dimensional gender
Spectrum along a Continuum would also be
necessary to better understand this um
later on the page it notes that one
trend ident identified as that more
young people are presenting to gender
clinics with non-binary
identities on the very last page has the
summary of the statement of
recommendations for adolescence and if
you look at
6.2 it states we recommend healthc Care
Professionals working with gender
diverse adolescents facilitate the
exploration and expression of gender
openly and respectfully so that no one
particular identity is favored that is
in essence what we tried to do when we
were looking to amend the statute on
conversion therapy nobody wants to force
a child to be somebody that they aren't
but the current language is not
accommodating to the current state of
knowledge around the um around how
gender identity is formed and it's also
not consistent with the w paath
guidelines um we we can figure out if we
do want to pursue um making any of these
changes to conversion th therapy or if
we would save that for um some other
time when we can bring in some experts I
think that might be better because
there's so many people just seeing these
headlines and not understanding the real
true work we're trying to do here to
make sure that nonb binary individuals
are respected as well I don't know if
there's any thoughts about whether we
should um whether we should proceed
looking at this or if that's something
that we should not do at this point I
think we should not do at all or right
now uh at all the uh people who um
testified uh the other week and then in
the spring were happy with how the
conversion therapy ban was worded and
I'm going to trust them on
that representative Canon um I I agree I
don't
microphone I uh I agree with
representative not up um that we
shouldn't address it here part of the
reason is because we're having a
dialogue about transgender
individuals we're not having a
discussion about
lgbtq people in total and that's the
problem here is that the what we're
talking about is is transgender people
and we haven't had in the the group of
people that were speaking we didn't have
the entire
lgbtq
population sharing and that's why in the
past when this when conversion of
therapy has come up as a separate bill
that we had an entire community of
people addressing all areas of that
could be affected by it conversion
therapy would
impact G and lesbian people as well as
transgender people and as such I don't
believe that we can do it justice in
this bill um thank you for that um I I
think that we had had that one
clarification on the wording but the
larger point is that um I I frankly
don't believe that non-binary people are
appropriately protected within that
conversion therapy statute but I think
we can leave that to another time um and
focus on Purely the genital gender
reassignment surgeries for minors
um so there's a whole Paradigm of care
that is outlined quite well in the wp
standard of care 8 um going back to this
first page it speaks about the um
eligibility criteria being imp
persistent long history of gender
non-conformity or dysphoria emerging or
intensifying the Onsen of puberty uh in
particular it also speaks to the absence
or management of psychological medical
or social problems that interfere with
treatment um I'm I'm very concerned um
with the idea that um that there's so
much of a focus on any one treatment
that um dealing with the larger scope
and and and reasons around suicidal
ideology is being pushed away with the
idea that the surgery will fix
everything and I'm afraid that that's a
very dangerous thought um it also speaks
about needing the support of people
around and most importantly the
provision of informed
consent
um I did want to make note that I had
made the point about the the fact that
when you're a teenager it feels like
everything needs to happen right away or
else it'll never happen and that was put
a lot more elegantly in the standard of
care here saying that adolescence often
experience a sense of urgency that stems
from hypers sensitivity to reward and
their sense of timing has been shown to
be different from that of older
individuals um that sites a study the
van lean horse at all from 2010 that's
on the second page and I think that it's
quite important to make sure that as we
look at this we try and understand and
balance their needs now and their
lifelong needs as
well so given the lifelong lications of
medical treatment and the young age at
which treatments may be started um
adolescents their parents and care care
providers should be informed about the
nature of the evidence base um it seems
that reasonable that decisions to move
forward with surgical treatment should
be made carefully and despite the slowly
growing body of evidence supporting the
effectiveness of early medical
intervention the number of studies is
still low and there are few outcome
studies that follow youth into adulthood
um and so the standard of care says that
a systematic review regarding outcomes
of treatment in adolescence is not
possible that's both medical and
surgical that's on the third P the
fourth page of this um
s46 the psychological function body
image and treatment statisfaction when
you look at a meta analysis of the data
in here only followed up from 3 months
to two years after the initiation of
treatment when we're talking about
surgical uh Surgical procedures we need
to make sure that the safety and
efficacy last longer than that you know
I spoke before about uh comparing this
to knee replacement surgery in knee
Replacements when you have your first
one um you you have a pretty good shot
at it it's usually going to work pretty
well but if it fails you need to remove
more bone and then you have the revision
one and that one might last 10 years
might last 15 hopefully Orthopedics has
improved since I I stopped paying as
much attention to it but after that and
you're in a wheelchair and that's just
your knee if you're talking about um
these surgeries we don't know what the
durability is we know that the gold
standard is a pretty good durability but
the newer procedures either with the
paranal lining or the um colonic lining
do not have any sort of idea as to how
long they'll last and I know that I'm
personally quite concerned that by
rushing into into a procedure um you may
end up unable to have that body part
that has been so crucial to you um
through a large amount of your lifetime
therefore I think we need to proceed
with
caution
see and then that gets to the quality of
evidence Dartmouth presented us with a
letter stating that this is well
researched we asked them for that
research and we were provided
with three points of information all of
them were on puberty blockers or hor hor
hores none were on
surgery if there is no data that can be
provided showing that this is in fact
well researched and safe and efficacious
um I'm very very very concerned about
the provision of this care in this state
um I've reached out against Dartmouth to
ask them for that information um but
nothing else has been
forthcoming I we have worked together to
um further narrow the amendment the one
that I brought brought that we brought
as the non- derain amendment had simply
taken the previous sections of the bill
um to not make too many changes to
Simply reduce that down to the genital
gender reassignment surgeries um this
one has not been drafted with OS because
they're under Inc incredible pressure
between both retain bills and our new
bills coming through um so they they've
confirmed that this is in the right
format and this is otherwise correct um
but they asked that I present it U non
formally today so so that means we can't
vote on it today um we can vote to have
this language in a work group we don't
have to have the actual amendment in
order to vote on it but in executive
session we need to have the actual
amendment
number I
see because we're just a casual group at
this point we've been named we've been
noticed we're having these meetings but
because we're not a quorum of the
meeting this is a directional um
indication to the full committee and not
a binding decision
so in narrowing it down it brings it to
a purpose stating that the legislature
finds that the following facts and
circumstances exist which make the
enactment of the statute necessary for
protection of minors and for furtherance
of the public interest Physicians have
an ethical and legal duty to obtain
patients informed consent before
ordering testing and treatment older
children and Adolescent should be asked
to provide their Ascent for treatment in
addition to their parents permission a
patient's informed consent requires
adequate information capacity toci side
and the absence of
coercion best practices urge shared
decision-making between parent or
parents and child and in general
preferring Alternatives that will not
foreclose important future choices by
the Adolescent and the adult the patient
will become multivariant analyses of
published studies between 2015 and 2022
showed no decrease in suicidality after
gender affirming surgery with some
studies showing a significant increase
in psychiatric hospitalizations and
suicide after surgical transition and
there's a lack of highquality clinical
trials which provide data on outcomes
for adolescent and genital gender
reassignment surgeries or young adult
genitor gender reassignment surgeries
particularly after pral suppression and
cross- seex
hormones finding that adolescent genital
gender reassignment surgery generally
lacks both adequate information for
informed consent and involves a high
risk of coercion for parental consent
when parents believe that they are faced
with a choice between their child
committing suicide or consenting to
their child's genital gender
reassignment surgeries and an AB the
absence of highquality data to prove
safety and efficacy including long-term
outcomes only people over the age of
majority should receive genital gender
reassignment surgery in the state of New
Hampshire it goes on to provide
definitions to really make sure that we
nail this down into
specifically to exclude include any
anything around a disorder of sex
development um which would be
malformations other ones to ex and just
to make sure that it's very clear what
is
included and then it pro it prohibits a
physician from performing genital gender
reassignment surgery on minors in the
state of New Hampshire and that's
defined as surgical procedures in people
born without disorders of sex
development including but not limited to
medas phalloplasty or vaginoplasty which
seek to change genitalia from male
genitalia to female genitalia from
female genitalia to male genitalia to
form a combination of male and female
genitalia or an absence of genitalia and
those born with exclusively male or
exclusively female genitalia or by
removing non-malignant
genitalia so um it does not prohibit
Physicians from performing
reconstructive surgeries on the
genitalia of miners to correct cor
malformation malignancy injury or
physical disease removal of malignant
malformed or otherwise damaged genitalia
genital surgeries on minors with
disorders of sex development or male
circumcision and then the enforcement um
is around it um referral or provision
being unprofessional conduct and to
allow action
um if if if it's found that somebody's
rights have been
violated so this is definitely whittling
down this bill to just the idea of the
genital gender reassignment
surgeries on
minors any
thoughts represent
Canon
um I'm concerned that we're putting a a
lot more into legislative effort that
that um probably should be left to the
medical
community um it's like we are not
MediCal experts we can read this which
is good stuff but if it changes over
time and we put it in the statute how
quickly can we change it in the statute
to reflect what's been changed by the
medical community if we leave this in
the hands of the medical community and
let them know they need to do their job
um that's a different story um uh the
the the people who put together the
world Prof World Professional
Association of transgender Health has
been around for a couple of decades and
before that it was the Harry Benjamin
standards of care so the people that
have been working on this and I know for
a fact they did not all agree with what
was being produced over time they had to
work together to make these things
happen that is an organization that is
focused on our transgender health New
Hampshire legislature is focused on
doing every everything for the community
in New Hampshire not just the
transgender this is a lot of text to put
into statute that could change over time
and if we have to change it it will take
a couple of years to change it in the
meantime there there are going to be
kids and families that are dependent on
the medical uh Community they're working
with to be able to make changes and to
do things to help them and so so to put
all this stuff into into statute is it's
crazy
representative
kushman thank you madam chair
um I respectfully um disagree with the
previous comments I just um I think that
when the interest of um children is on
the table if the research
changes there's a reason that our
process takes so long that everything
goes through um a lot of scrutiny you
know multiple um hearings in both bodies
and um you know we do the amendment
process we hear from the public and what
has been failed to be demonstrated here
is that these are um efficacious and
long and have long-term benefit that has
not been demonstrated and I think that
in order to protect this is a very small
subset of people who goes for this kind
of treatment but there is a history uh
disturbing history and unfortunate one
in medicine where minorities have been
exploited um you know through the
practices um that have been employed and
I think here is a appropriate place for
the legislature to step in and say put a
pause on it in the state of New
Hampshire if Massachusetts wants to
continue to allow these surgeries it's
not very far to go there and and seek
and seek this care if it's for that very
small number um Dartmouth said it's very
rare that it occurs in children but they
could not tell us that it doesn't happen
here in children and they didn't give us
a number they also didn't provide their
policies and procedures for deciding how
uh for um how it's decided if a minor is
going to receive that care nor a body of
evidence um demonstrating that this is
okay so
I the way I see it is if
the um if the the literature changes and
that takes years in itself then the
legislature can then meet again and do
its job and determine if the evidence is
sufficient enough um to representatives
of the people to allow these surgeries
in New Hampshire but right now I don't
see
that representative Missour yeah thank
you I me mentioned in the last hearing I
brought up the the billing codes and
how it was very clear to me in research
and and asking people that there were
billing codes in place in another state
um
for transition
surgery but there was no billing codes
for backtracking out of that and uh that
became a serious issue so you I would
like to
see things like that in place so
that that doesn't happen here so a
child gets through a certain part of of
a process and then has no way back and
then has then has no way to pay for it
or anything like that like they're
really is no turning back um at and when
we're talking
minors like these could be small
children that we've heard de
developmentally it's like the age of
26 that things keep changing um you know
we hear
about tattoos and um
tanning that's
not that is not allowed for minors there
are reasons behind that so I hear you
when you say putting statutes in place
but we have statutes in place for other
things
that you C you can't turn back on this
so this seems like a way more serious
thing that you know and I and I heard
last time too someone mentioned that
this is an attack on um a certain
community and that that's not what this
is at all because many of us have
friends in this community this is um if
you're an adult and this is you go do
your thing you know as adults do our
thing we are talking specifically about
minors and children um that have a huge
future ahead of them and so
they're why not you know get go through
um the therapy and the processes that we
do have in place and then you know at a
certain age if that's still the
direction they want to go then that's
their decision but you know there is we
are here as a legislature to stand for
our children and for many of us that's
what this is so to be to be told that
this is an attack on that is personally
highly offensive um because that's not
what this is a lot I think of people
just see this as um a protection for for
kids that they're not quite there you
know with making that decision and um so
that's my take
on representative
Canon here's my concern is for the
families with children that are faced
with gender dysphoria is that we might
be limiting the options they have to
save their
child and and uh that's one of the
concerns that I have with with this bill
even if it's just being presented
because I know that there's a lot of
children out there that are challenged
that are looking to where are they going
and that they're not accepted and if we
as a legislature are putting new things
in place they may not understand why
we're doing that it just looks like
someone just put a wall up and I'm not
going to get past it and and maybe I
need to do something else about it and
that's scary there are therapy
procedures though in
place right now like so that is
providing assistance to them it's not
like there's nothing available
right tell that to the child and the
parent that's all already bringing their
child of therapy who's struggling um
I've seen inter with adults even that
are struggling they go into therapy for
things and then eventually they take
their life because they don't see a
future for themselves so I'm just I'm
just putting it out there if we as we
move forward I recognize that we're
protecting children we have to and there
are lots of things that the medical
community is take is put in place and
needs to work but if we as a legislature
said no to that we put it in statute
this is all you can get and and this
we're we're doing something that limits
things and and that's I'm saying if it
changes in the medical community they
can change it in the medal Community
when it comes if it changes there we
need to change it as a statute it could
take two years to get it changed so in
the meantime we have we have a family
with kids that needs some assistance and
we have a statute that says no you can't
do
that
representative and then my understanding
that the the main um gist of this bill
is to make sure that uh gender
reassignment surgeries do not happen uh
under the age of 18 right and I agree
with that and as far as I heard from
everything I heard from Dartmouth they
don't do it uh someone else on our
committee said it's on their website you
know you don't get gender reassignment
surgery under 18 so I think we're going
kind of far a field um I think we can
agree you know we don't like to dictate
uh to
prescriptively um to what um doctors can
do what what insurance companies can pay
for or not but I think we can a agree on
um those kinds of
surgeries don't need to happen in New
Hampshire under 18 so I'm not sure we
even need this bill if those surgeries
are not happening under 18 I believe
they're not I I believe others perhaps
are more skeptical so um there's you
know we don't need to be emotional uh
about this it's always very important to
protect children um those of us who have
raided teenagers you know understand um
changing of minds and growing into to
new uh thoughts and you know all the all
the changes that that happen but you
know the the Bare Bones of this is no
surgeries under 18 and I think we can
agree on that so uh you know we we can't
discuss all developmental teenager stuff
we would be here for years so anyway I'd
have teams by then representative
kushman thank you um so on the on the
other side um of Representative Canon's
um
point at the same time if if it takes
two years to change the law the other
way if the research catches up to
it that that was your argument you know
in the meantime those kids would be
maybe not have access to this certain
care
um which I don't see a good evidence
base for in the one um hospital that
says that they do it but rarely in
minors
um on the other side of that if we don't
pass this bill they acknowledge that
it's rare they did not outright say that
they don't do it and have not done
it I have personally
heard um of people children in New
Hampshire sure who have received
surgeries and meanwhile that can all
take place without clinical trial data
showing the eff efficacy of these
surgeries on miners for the long
term and I mean like surgical clinical
trials where they compare the surgery to
other treatments and therapies and have
a control group also and you know there
there's no systemic reviews on this
there's no meta analyses all I've
received so far are very are small
studies that look at either surveys um
telling about suicidal ideation with
puberty blockers or with
hormones um and they don't go long term
so in the meantime we without evidence
to show that this is clinically safe and
I'm not just talking about suicide
adiation wise there are kids who are
going to be harmed by this
irreversibly if we don't pass this
bill representative
Canon I I think if we're looking for
that kind of information we should be
working with the world professional
association from transgender health
because those folks are doing this to
try and and are tracking this the same
type of information you're asking for
it's not being done state byst state
it's not being done uh uh
outside of the medical community um so
we're we're talking about things that
are already being done at a at a medical
level uh and not in not here we we are
not MediCal experts we're totally
dependent on the medical community to
get this information just like just like
introducing a new drug and and all this
it needs that testing and stuff it
doesn't happen by us the state agency
it's totally dependent on the industry
that's that's doing it now having said
that I really appreciate what you've
been doing here it I it's it's trying
it's trying to narrow the focus and make
sure that we're not hurting
kids that that's that that is what
ultimately we need to do I'm what I'm
trying to say is here in the legislature
is it our job to to do all of the
medical review all that analysis is it
and to have that and make our decisions
made or should we go back to the medical
community is it you have a duty to the
public to do your job their job is is
not to hurt someone it's physician
heal people and if they're not doing
that they're not doing their job but
should we put that into statute as far
as all this detail goes and if we do
this and we're focused on the
transgender Community are we not
discriminating against all those other
groups I mean this this group can
compare to other groups we don't have
things in for the MS Community we don't
have things for kids with autism there's
a whole spectrum of of child care things
that need to be addressed this is just
one community of people and right now uh
this is from my my perspective this is
discrimination we've zero in one and
we're telling it we're taking it out of
the medical community's hands who are
involved with all these different things
and now we're going to put it in the
legislature and it says discrimination
all over it because it's just a very
small community of kids and people and
and uh as far as I'm concerned and and
the community is concerned it's really
focused and and I understand your focus
on in this particular Community but
there's also other communities that have
have surgical needs and medical needs
and therapy needs and we're not
addressing any of that maybe in doing
this we ought to be addressing all those
too so that's that's what bothers me is
we just zeroed in on one community of
kids um and we if if we do that for one
part of the community shouldn't we be
doing it for all of we this as far as
I'm concerned and as far as many people
are concerned this is discrimination and
we have laws against that and the
transgender Community including kids are
called out in the we should not be
discriminating in kids and as far as I'm
concerned this stuff although it's good
information is discrimination this ought
to be in the working between families
the kids
and their medical care providers because
it it's not a simple thing uh I know
this because I I went through this whole
process myself and working with the
medical community to get my care and it
was not a simple thing it's not I'm
gonna I'm going to go get surgery no
it's not it's many years of therapy it's
many years of assistance it's it's even
when I decided to get my think it took a
full year and I ended up talking with a
lot of people I had to provide
statements from my therapist my
psychologist my PCP my
endocrinologist um and and a couple
others to to even get in the door and
then then I had to speak with three
different surgeons who were going to be
part of the surgical procedures it took
a year and even then when I went in for
my surgeries I got asked about six times
do you know what you're
doing they are experts at what they do
but they also are people they really
care about their patients and and
that's this putting it into legislation
is is taking some of that away from that
those people that care for kids we' put
it down not only do they have to figure
out what is the medical community tell
me what's the best thing to do to help
this child with with current knowledge
and current tools and then they have to
go back and say to the state what can I
do based on what you put in statute and
are are we limiting the care that
someone can get by doing this um my
question would U is sorry my question
regarding the discriminatory law would
be questioning if in 1970 we had put in
a Prohibition to prohibit the prohibit
doctors from failing to provide
antibiotics to black men with syphilis
if protecting that Minority Community by
preventing a medical practice that was
happening would have been discriminatory
or if it would have been
protective I think that's a little far
field um and we're we're talking about
the whether medical guidelines are the
end all be all or if occasionally
there's time for the legislation of
Representative n I'm sorry I didn't mean
to stuff on your toes no um um
representative
Canon we're we're this bill is focused
on children and you know we've heard
your story and we care for you and all
those things but I I want to focus back
on um I I think we're at at a point are
we not able to vote whether this
subcommittee recommends or not and then
we take it to our executive um meeting
on Monday and then it goes I as I say to
the 400 you know to the full house so um
we can we can do a lot of sidebars here
but it could be a long day and uh we are
in agreement on some minor issues I am a
little I will leave it to OS to decide
if this language is something that one
puts in a bill it seems more of a a a
summary of um facts it seems a little
out of form to me but I'm not an expert
in that so I'm going to leave it to them
and leave it to the Judgment of our
fellow legislators um about how we
proceed from here representative M I
just have a just
a respectfully I I I hear your story
and that and correct me if I'm wrong you
you went through you know as an adult
that those procedures as an adult um
whereas you know I just heard from she
stood up in front of group of people
last week and yes this is in
Massachusetts but that's the thing is
like knowing that that could happen here
is really you know disturbing to me that
in Massachusetts she walked in um you
know as a minor and within 45 minutes
this is a doctor she didn't go to a
therapist or anything within 45 minutes
was put on
testosterone and then soon after walked
in you know and then was able to have a
double myectomy no therapy at all she'll
tell you this she and she was here at at
our hearing when we when we first did
this and and since then she's in her 20s
and all of her reproductive organs have
been removed and she is so when you know
I we hear that your story we hear that
story it but it's it's finding the
balance of you know and as
representative Nutter upam said we're
talking about
children and that's our focus and we're
talking about genital reassignment
surgery only on children that you can't
go back on that's the thing we're
talking about exactly we're not trying
to outlaw therapy right and um uh
hormone blockers which you know as
uh um children are going through puberty
earlier and earlier for we're not sure
what reasons and so there's a lot of
other reasons besides wanting to change
their gender or sex that whatever so
um many of the stories that you know
people have told are are a little
terrifying and frightening but I'd like
to you know pull us back to with what we
agree on is the yeah and I think this
bill now is a testament to this
subcommittee and the work that we've
done in getting it to the roof
you know look at the things that have
been removed from it that's a that's a
testament that we've been listening to
people and we've been making the changes
you know and so we have there's a lot of
stuff that's been removed from this
because we are listening to PE you know
all communities um and you and parents
and PE you know people in in the
different communities so I think the
work that we've done in getting this
bill to where it's at now is is
something
and I do have one other part about the
fact that we don't always the doctors
aren't always following all of the
clinical guidelines in the W path
standard of care 8 it says that
providers should be prepared to support
adolescent who do R transition and it
states uh it it cites a study the
vanderbush uh 2021 study saying that
many of them expressed difficulties
finding help during their Dre transition
process and it was an isolating there
reported their D transition was an
isolating experience during which they
did not receive either sufficient or
appropriate support despite best
practices and despite the fact that
people are working and trying to do
their absolute best some doctors are
humans too those who set the policies
for hospitals are humans too um and
that's why I believe that taking these
findings from the W path would state
that there are not those data on there
is not sufficient data yet and they see
that they need to give to a narrative
review as opposed to a meta analysis
because there are not sufficient data
data to even provide a meta analysis
within the standard of care I think
that's why I think that's why it's
appropriate to act here and quite
frankly the reason why there is this
information regarding sort of the state
of where medicine is now is so that if
the standard of care nine comes out and
there's a bunch of clinical evidence
that shows that that what was in place
when we put this into law is no longer
fact that will be a great reason for a
future legislature to reverse course and
say actually no now there is high
quality data that proves the safety and
efficacy of um of gender genital
reassignment surgeries with the
procedures that are offered to minors if
when that data is there there goes that
argument um but the data are not there
and I believe that protect that that
this is the way to protect um I think we
may we may have reached the conclusion I
don't want to stop anybody from
speaking I'd recognize a
motion you probably do you want to
representative kushman um I move that we
recommend to the full committee that we
adopt this amendment
language um when it comes to the full
committee okay and seconded by
representative
Missour I think we've had enough
discussion so I can call the role would
that be correct y okay representative n
upam no representative Canon no
representative Missour yes
representative Kush yes representative
Shapiro is not here and representative
Lon is yes so that would be uh two to
one with one absence to recommend that
this language be drafted into an
official Amendment for the committee to
adopt so if there's not any further
discussion oh yes representative missor
so representative nupen can you clarify
to me then so when you I heard you
say um I think it was just to move it
along just she wasn't ready to make the
motion but she wanted somebody to make
the motion just because she didn't think
we were going to come to a full
agreement okay was that the
question yes and
no
okay
okay okay thank you um
representative kushman just a point of
order you said it was two to one it was
three to sorry three to two Okay I
apologize the migraine is prepped in in
one absence thank you
okay and with that I will close this
work session on House Bill 619 thank you
thank
you